thank you all so much for coming out to
see me my name is Emily arnut this is my
first time at strange Loop my first time
in the city of St Louis which uh seems
absolutely beautiful uh and I realized
yesterday this is actually the furthest
south I've ever been which is uh a
little bit of an
achievement uh it's a honestly
Bittersweet to be here I read Doug
Douglas Hoffs I am strange Loop almost
10 years ago it had a tremendous impact
on me and to learn that there was this
whole conference this wonderful
community that was inspired by those
ideas uh and then to have the privilege
of coming and speaking at it I was just
so moved I was so touched and then I
learned that it was also the last one
which is uh a little disheartening but
I'm sure the spirit will keep living on
um but that's enough sentimentality for
now I have a little intro for you here
on my
phone
good afternoon everyone I know I know
yet another talk on AI you're probably
thinking you've heard it all from AI
saving the world to it accidentally
ordering a thousand rubber ducks instead
of just the one now in the realm of
software Incident Management AI can
truly be our night and shining armor but
like any medieval KN there's a chance it
might just joust its way through the
wrong door and if you're suspecting I
got an AI to write this intro well let's
just say I'm keeping some cards close to
my chest and then it says wink I don't
know if I'm supposed to say wink or
wink a little
unclear but as you may have guessed and
AI did write that intro for me uh this
is the prompt I gave it and I'm sure
it's no surprise to you now that AI can
deliver a pretty meaningful response
this prompt I asked for a brief one
paragraph intro I talked about you know
this is the subject of my talk but I
wanted it to cover the helpfulness the
potential risk I said oh please please
make it humorous put some jokes in there
please acknowledge that the audience has
already heard you know even just today
two more talks about AI how who knows
how many before that they they've
probably even seen this trick before of
you know a stealthy AI introduction
where you go oh wow did you know that
was actually just chat GPT and then I
even specified don't don't say that
explicitly I want that to be a surprise
I don't think it was much of a surprise
so let's examine my prompt a little bit
let's do a little bit of psychoanalysis
of what this prompt represents it's very
specific I gave it a particular topic
and then all sorts of requirements on
top of that it seems a little neurotic
obviously like uh it's a level of demand
that I think uh if you were giving your
human employees that much specific
they would be a little peeved but it
comes from a place of nervousness like
this is the biggest stage I've ever
spoken on and I'll be honest I was a
little nervous I needed some sort of way
to ease myself in from a place of
uncertainty I wasn't really sure what
was the audience going to be like
specifically how can I kind of like
hedge my bets a little bit and from a
place of novelty there's an excitement
there you want to bravely go into this
new water and you want AI to kind of
lead you there um and this is not too
unlike an engineer when they're doing
incident response when something breaks
and they have to diagnose it and solve
it it's the same sort of mentality the
same sort of neurosis the same need for
specificity and the same
nervousness but my request was not
something that you would really ever ask
of a human as I said that would maybe
get you labeled as a bit of a
micromanager and that got me thinking
you know maybe an incident response we
should be asking some things that aren't
human IE
AI so I come from a world where we live
and breathe incidents and something that
we found is that the definition of an
incident what is and what isn't is a
little bit nebulous and for this talk I
would really recommend we take a very
broad holistic picture uh one that isn't
so much about the qualities of the thing
itself but more about the effect it has
on you so what I mean by that is let's
take a look at your typical workday you
have a planned task then you know
there's going to be a follow-up task to
that a follow-up task to that and then
at the end you get a nice well-earned
rest but let's take a look at what
happens when an incident interferes you
have your planned task that goes fine
you're doing your follow-up task and
then something unexpected this could be
anything this could be all of your
services are down this could be hey
we've got this bug that we're going to
really prioritize because it could lead
to another problem this could be
unexpected staff changes pull you into a
meeting and suddenly your whole day is
just spent on reorganizing the or charts
no matter what it is you need to have
some sort of process in place so that
you're not scrambling doing everything
ad hoc you need incident response and at
the end of that response process
whatever it involves you need to make
systemic improvements to prevent
recurrence then after that it's back to
business as
usual not always usually it's back to
staring at a screen trying to remember
what was it that I was doing again and
then in a St instead of a well-earned
rest it's more about trying to catch up
so I hope that this very broad holistic
perspective on incidents can really make
you appreciate that it's something that
all of us deal with in our work in our
personal lives in our Hobbies whatever
projects anything that's pulling you
away from your plan you should have a
process
for so what makes incident response so
challenging there's a lot of words on
this slide and that's because there's a
lot of reasons that inent response is
challenging and I'm not going to say
that AI is a magic wand solution that is
going to solve all of these
automatically instantly forever but
we'll see how AI being applied to even
just a few key ones of these can create
like a positive domino effect where the
additional time energy
and de-stress that you get from these
time-saving measures can help you handle
all this other stuff probably the
biggest one with Incident Management is
time sensitivity you're acutely aware
that every second the incident persists
is delaying you from your planned work
it's creating this cascading slowdown
effect you could also be incurring a ton
of other costs too if it's a major
outage then you have no one using your
service and no one making you money
frankly uh there's a lot of expertise
requ quired in resolving an incident
usually you need a lot of deep knowledge
of your code base to figure out what are
the root causes here what bugs could
have changed what has made the situation
different from the stable State before
often when responding to an incidents
you'll have a lot of tedious and very ad
hoc subtasks suddenly you're going to be
in a position where you're manually
checking through dozens of lines of code
that should have like been taken care of
already there's also a huge coordination
commun communication problem with
incident response how do you get all of
the necessary people into the room or
virtual room at once how do you make
sure work isn't done redundantly how do
you make sure you're being effective and
finally it's all about retaining and
using what you learn you can't just be
running into the same pitfalls every
single day you need to at some point
build a
bridge okay so I think the best way to
think about how AI fits into this
process and maybe makes things easier
for you you is to look at a crisis
scenario and this is a bad one 75% of
your users simply cannot log into your
service so this is severity zero the
absolute Max all Hands-On deck of course
you know
75% uh loss of traffic loss of Revenue
that's no good the most frustrating part
in this scenario is that you can't
delineate what is success and what is
failure you don't really understand
why it is that 25% of people can still
log
in so you think okay let's try to
examine our codebase let's look for
plausible causes of bugs that could have
created this problem but you've got a
huge code base this is your first Ro
block a user logging in actually ping
pongs through all sorts of different
files you might have to pulse in some
profile data and kind of build out how
the service looks to that particular
user there could be Security checks
which may be subcontracted to a third-
party tool and then that creates a whole
big mess as well there's cookie
management you need to synchronize their
experience with what the the service
expects and it's a difficult question to
say where does all of this live in your
code base it's probably like in a dozen
or more places and unless you guys are
like wizards of documentation there's
probably not just one key word you can
search for that pulls it all up and
beyond that you also want to know where
does this live in the code base that has
been changed recently you're looking for
that cause and effect relationship and
uh I don't know like has anyone had this
sort of experience you you've had an
issue you've had a bug and it's like
where do I even start it's like 80
places it could
be AI can be your sidekick here this is
already a very common use case for chat
GPT and other Lang large language models
parsing code with natural language and
asking natural language questions about
it so typically these days uh models
like chat gbt you can dump in maybe like
one Function One chunk of code and get
pretty reasonable results but kind of
invariably no matter what technology you
are optimistic for it seems like
something that's happening is llms being
able to scale larger and larger input
data we're hearing now about models that
can take in like a whole novel can say
read war in peace for me tell me what
are the themes of war in peace and this
is actually becoming a reasonable thing
to expect from AI so similarly we can
imagine that in the
future and perhaps even in the present
you could dump in significant parts of
your code base if not the whole thing
and expect to have like a meaningful
contextual relationship emerge then you
can just simply ask in natural language
hey can you highlight everything that
has to do with logging in can you
highlight everything that has to do with
with logging in that's received some
push in that file in the last week you
can start narrowing in just using your
own judgment and not requiring this like
specific expertise of oh but that
connects to that connects to that and
actually we're still using this old
function just for logging in and all of
this tribal knowledge that who knows
where it
exists okay so let's say you succeed you
find this chunk of code uh let's say
it's something that very fundamentally
just parses the input from when you log
in just on the level of like taking the
text and moving it somewhere to further
analyze and you suspect this because
there was a recent Global change to your
entire service that impacted like every
input to that service that that kind of
seems like the culprit you can't just
roll back this change though you're
that's going to break like way too many
things but you you know that the error
is happening here it's just kind of
within this one chunk of code but you
can't quite weasel out
what is making it work sometimes what is
it making it fail sometimes so how do
you figure out what inputs are breaking
it you could do it manually you could
try to manually come up with some
automation for it but all of these
things are pretty stressful pretty
tedious and toilsome in the midst of
this crisis in the midst of 75% of your
users being shown the door so how do you
figure this out without losing your
mind and uh here's another common
existing use case for llms ad hoc script
generation uh this is probably something
that all of my programmer friends do on
a weekly basis if not more you just need
a little thing done you give it very
minimal information hey I need you to
test these fields with this types of
input uh please output the results in
this format and you're Off to the Races
just going to grab a drink of water one
second as you ruminate on this I'm sure
a lot of you in the room have done that
right a little GPT script
generation okay so let's say this all
just works great you've fixed everything
and the users can log in are we done now
no we are if anything just getting
started this incident has exposed a
major flaw in your system namely that
these deep systemic changes on input
can break higher level Stu like logins
so how do you fix this on a systemic
level well it's kind of difficult right
like we said before the login process is
somewhat distributed there's probably a
lot of different owners for different
parts of the code that deal with this
and as I said it ties into this global
inputting system to your service so
probably multiple teams
involved um and to get them all up to
speed on what needs to be done and what
broke you're going to have to spend
hours in meetings and remember none of
this is your planned work this whole
time you're hoping to get back to those
initial tasks you laid
out so once again our AI sidekick can
leap in with incident retrospectives and
communication so this is something that
a lot of organizations are already
making a priority every time something
breaks you draft up a little report of
it you include a timeline who was
talking to two what was tried what
failed what worked um but AI can really
kind of enhance this build targeted
reports without you needing to submit
much organization on your end um and
what you're aiming for is a model of the
incident something that's been trained
to know what happened that can then be a
subject matter expert to other Engineers
so that rather than going to you who's
busy with a lot of other work or a
well-earned rest they can just go to
this model of the retrospective that can
kind of answer questions bring them up
to speed on what they need to know and
help guide them along to the uh solution
like Distributing that solution to other
situations so all this sounds pretty
great right these are big big
opportunities you're reducing the stress
and toil of Engineers you're minimizing
the downtime when something breaks and
because of all of that you're
accelerating your planned work it's a a
real compound
Advantage but it comes with risks I'm
sure everyone here can think of an
example of Engineers a very famous case
they encountered an incident a problem
while out in deep space and collaborated
with an AI to uh disasters
results now I don't think any large
language model you implement is going to
attempt murder but there are some things
that it will likely do that you need to
compensate for the first one I want to
talk about is black boxing um there's a
lot of people that use AI but don't
fully understand what is going on the
inside and by a lot of people I mean
basically everyone the goal of AI is to
create something that has kind of power
and utility uh beyond what you yourself
are capable of and similarly if you get
AI to write a chunk of code let's say
this one that helps you parse what
logins are working or not working you go
hey that's actually a pretty useful tool
I'm I'm probably going to need this for
future incidents we could even maybe
incorporate this into the codebase
somehow but you know exactly how it
works do you know line by line what it's
doing maybe in simple cases yes but the
more you rely on the AI the more you
take advantage of its speed the less
you'll be able to have that confidence
in every single line of code and that's
okay because you probably don't have
that level of confidence of every single
line of human written code in your code
base the thing is it creates Tech debt
it creates a very specific type of tech
debt where there's little black boxes in
your code space where you just have to
trust things are going to go in and come
out the way you're expecting so the way
you deal with this is the way that you
deal with any sort of tech you just
acknowledge that you are going to
accumulate it nobody's perfect nobody
can do 100% code reviews 100% of the
time and you just find ways to schedule
time to deal with it to gain back some
confidence in your system to clean up
spaghetti code and black boxes to
document things and I I think you know
it's just a tradeoff all of these things
we talk about are tradeoffs with AI you
get the speed and convenience but you
just need to invest in protocol that can
compensate for
that the next one is
hallucination this is by far the most
common problem that people experience
with uh large language models um it's
something that is basically inherently
going to be the case with them based on
how they work if you ask an llm a
question uh let's say what is the
library function from AWS that does this
thing and you're in the middle of an
incident you want to response quickly
you think this is the best way to get it
and the AI very confidently tells you in
proper formatting hey just call this
function with these arguments and you'll
get what you need you slott it into your
code you're sitting pretty you think
that was easy and you immediately get
that squiggly Red Line this function
does not exist uh the AI loves
confidently making stuff up when it
thinks it has to it's kind of like you
know when you're in school and you're
asked a question and you just don't want
to admit that you don't know like maybe
you think oh I was supposed to read that
so you just BS whatever you can and hope
you can kind of get through it that's
what the AI is always wanting to do uh
and here I think the best system to have
in place is is just like another layer
of Sanity check like I said this will
never totally be rooted out in AIS and
again it's like you can't spend all day
just kind of babysitting it and policing
it so it's important to just kind of set
yourself up that you can't be
catastrophically destroyed by
incorporating some bad data or making a
bad
assumption desynchronization is a
particular type of hallucination so AI
uh large language models are kind of
trained at a specific time and place
they have a data set that they work on
to use to make their model um and that
only happens at certain periods you you
can't expect to be constantly updating
your model whether that's feeding at
your latest code base you can't expect
to do that every time a line of code
changes or you know pulling terabytes
and terabytes from the internet uh every
weekend so you you have to accept that
whatever model you use is going to be a
little out of touch with the latest
greatest and again it's all just about
building checks and balances into the
procedure uh you just have to embrace
the idea that AI could be saving you a
lot of time so why not just spend a
little bit of extra time and make sure
it's giving you something
good so another major issue with AI that
I think is going to be taking the
Forefront more and more as
we uh entrust strategically uh more and
more advanced models of AI
which is Mis
prioritization so let's go back to our
login issue but think about like a
modified version of it uh 75% of users
still can't log in only 25% can get in
and you have no idea why nothing has
work so far even with your AI buddy
you're not really making much progress
but you do come up with a way to let in
an additional 10% of users of your
choice this is maybe a little convoluted
I'm not sure why this would ever happen
happen but I hope it's illustrative how
do you decide which 10% to let in could
it be the 10% that spend the most money
when they're using your service is it
the 10% that are currently most
dissatisfied and likely to switch to a
competitor if they don't have a good
experience right now uh there's a whole
lot of ways you could determine this
like selection filter and you have a ton
of user data to parse in order to do so
so obviously you want to get automation
involved and then there's kind of a
Spectrum to how much trust you give the
AI you can give it very very explicit
instructions on how to sort this user
data and make
prioritizations and that's essentially
just kind of like a big Excel filter in
sort or if you're really press for time
and you're confident in the AI you can
start asking it to think more and more
strategically leave it up to its
Judgment of which users are the highest
value and this can actually be quite
powerful like I think even current AI
models have a good enough kind of
linguistic understanding to figure out
things like oh making money is good
customers leaving is bad dissatisfaction
correlates with leaving but the thing is
these are only linguistic relations
they're not facts that the AI knows
about the world and you'll run into
these issues of Mis prioritization where
the further you entrust these things to
the AI the farther off course they're
going to be able to steer
so once again it's a trade-off you save
a lot of time and effort by letting it
make these judgment calls but they might
not be the right
calls
so one thing I really want to emphasize
and I hope that with this crowd it goes
without saying but the benefits of AI
are not an excuse to downsize you should
not be thinking oh I have 10x Engineers
now they've been 10 xifi by AI that
means I can fire nine engineers I I'm
sure nobody here has had that thought
but some people have and I think it's
important to really proactively address
that AI should be seen as an investment
in your people it's something that
empowers Engineers it's something that
makes their lives easier and allows them
to get more of the work they planned on
done and in order to really reinforce
this message and to continue getting the
most set of your people you need to keep
investing in those people not just in AI
so does that look
like first I really want to emphasize
process you need a robust and resilient
process so AI is going to break things
in ways we can't currently imagine you
are probably going to get some bizarre
errors from using AI written code or
weird resource allocation issues from AI
driven testing and things are going to
break in ways you've never seen before
that's scary the nice thing though is
that a novel problem doesn't always need
a totally novel solution there are
fundamental things you can do every time
something breaks that will always always
work for you you're always going to need
to figure out who are the people best
equipped to deal with this process how
do we alert them are they on call are
they burnt out are they able to help how
do we get them coordinating with each
other all of these sorts of logistical
higher-end questions are things that you
need to solve with proc C and what I
mean by like robust and resilient
robustness kind of means completeness
like you can account for everything you
can think of uh which is difficult with
AI so you also need resilience which is
where it's flexible and can adapt and
bounce back when hit with things that
you couldn't currently imagine which is
maybe a lot of
AI I really think investing in process
is what's going to separate you know the
successful companies and the companies
that end up lagging behind when a
gigantic explosive new technology like
AI
emerges the next thing I want to
emphasize is that AI is still in its
infancy relative to a lot of technology
that we work with and the pace at which
it's evolving and changing and giving
you new features and options is
mind-boggling like I feel like every day
I learn about some thrilling new AI
development and if you're implementing
AI in your workspace especially with
something like Incident Management you
can't afford not to stay on top of these
things like something like hallucination
I said was you know just an inherent
problem with AI but it is getting better
um in the talk before ours we saw how AI
itself can actually start addressing uh
when it's not confident or when it
thinks it's making something up these
are things that are just emerging now
that can make your AI tools more
reliable especially in this place where
reliability is so crucial of Incident
Management
another thing I really think we ought to
do explicitly is train Engineers in AI
operations now the big thing about AI is
that it's easy right like you use
natural language you just ask typical
questions and you get amazing results
you can be neurotic you can be nervous
you can be specific it doesn't matter
it'll handle things for you but still
there's a lot of small nuances in how
you communicate with the AI that can
have big impact in the sort of results
you get again in the previous talk we
saw some great examples of this um I've
heard all sorts of things about if you
give it prompts that start with think
about this step by step and give me a
solution it does a lot better uh I even
heard if you say take a deep breath and
give me the answer to this which is just
like really disturbingly anthropic but
that's just the world we live in now um
so teaching engineers about these
techniques letting them have time to
experiment to develop their own
practices around this um can make a
world of difference not just in terms of
getting better results from the AI but
showing that you're willing to invest in
your engineers along with this new
technology and they're not just going to
be replaced by like prompt Engineers or
you know somebody that has been hired in
to specialize on this you got to take
steps with your people and with your
technology so thinking about the issue
with AI being you know a little
strategically misguided not having the
same priorities as you the real problem
here is that often your engineers don't
do much better and it's not the fault of
Engineers everyone here everyone that
works in Tech is a very smart person
that understand the fundamentals of what
running a good business is but nobody
can really have that broad a perspective
while they're also drilling away on
jurats they have you know a very linear
path path of what they want to work on
and I think that creates a problem this
creates uh an issue in many cases not
just with dealing with AI where
Engineers don't have the full context of
the organization that allows them to
make these more strategic decisions so I
think as you bring on AI tools you need
to empower Engineers to do this thing
that humans are still so uniquely good
at which is prioritize based on the big
picture prioritize based on like Common
Sense human think
like making money is good losing
customers is bad that AI we can only
just hope and assume
understand I I think this is really
going to be the turning point for a lot
of people's careers um nobody wants to
be in a position where they're being
replaced by Ai and so everyone should be
given opportunities to enhance
themselves and to take on that more
strategic
role along those lines um you really
need to celebrate the work people are
doing around incidents uh I would say
right now the overall sentiment towards
AI is mixed at best we have a lot of
people out there that see AI as a threat
or they see it as trying to delegitimize
work that they have done uh they see it
minimalizing and marginalizing uh the
contributions they make and these are
problems that uh incident workers face
already incident work falls into a
category of what has been called very
famously glue work it's stuff that kind
of keeps everything together but if it's
done well you don't even notice it among
those seams and people that do glue work
often feel burnt out and unappreciated
and
unrecognized uh it's often too thankless
and it leaves people looking for other
opportunities it leaves you with churn
and not a very stable product so I think
as you incorporate Ai and as these
Engineers deal with you know the confle
conflicting feelings of oh this is such
a great opportunity this makes things so
easy but oh my God is it so easy now
that they can just fire me and I don't
even need to be involved um a way to
reassure people is with this celebration
recognize achievements recognize what
the human still does to
contribute uh lastly and if you look up
the company I work for you'll understand
uh why this is so important to me and
why I saved it for last I work for a
company called blameless um building a
blameless culture is so important to
incident response in general and I think
will only become more important as these
AI Technologies get involved so what I
mean by blamelessness is when something
goes wrong you don't look for like an
individual who is at fault sure maybe
someone did make a mistake maybe they
pushed some code that they shouldn't
have and then everything broke but if
you just stop at like punishing that
person saying never do that again you're
fired whatever how will that lead to any
sort of improvement that's like a very
shallow approach to dealing with the
problem instead you need to wonder what
is happening on the systemic level that
let this happen what sort of checks and
balances can we
incorporate uh to prevent this sort of
thing from recurring and that's what
blameless is all is all about it's about
digging deeper into these systemic
causes so what I'd likeing to people to
do when they start having these AI
agents as Sidekicks is to not just blame
the AI either sure maybe it hallucinated
some weird Library function and
everything didn't work because of that
sure maybe it generated the most
convoluted input Checker of all time and
now nobody knows how to use it and that
creates another problem that's like it's
mistake but what can you do on the
systemic level to prevent that mistake
from happening
again so in summary I think I might be
like way ahead of time
I I don't know what the time check is
but uh we can do a thorough summary here
of the as promised in the title risks
and
opportunities the opportunities are
wonderful less stress more time for
Planned work happier users experiencing
less downtime the risks of course are
Tech debt weird new bugs and Engineers
that may feel a little bit alienated by
this new technology so how do you
mitigate invest in process keep learning
the best practices and advancing uh
along with this exciting new technology
train your engineers to deal with AI
specifically Empower that sense of a
greater perspective that strategic
thinking celebrate the work they do show
that people are
appreciated and have a blameless culture
that extends to AI that helps you
address things
systemically uh so I thought it would be
appropriate to end things with a
farewell from our new sidekick once
again I gave it a almost impossibly
neurotic task of another brief one
paragraph outro touching on helping
resolve incidents faster with less toil
automate scripts code-based parsing also
enabling follow-up improvements with
better reporting and communication
please touch on how investing in the
humans is important uh process
resilience is important mitigates risk
and also make it funny please don't
forget to make it funny you got to make
it memorable make sure the audience
feels they've seen a glimpse of an
exciting new future era of Incident
Management this is this is a tall order
to be sure let's see how it
did all right folks to wrap up our
journey today think of AI and Incident
Management like a hyperactive but
brilliant
intern it's a pretty good joke I don't
know it's it's uh relatable it'll raise
through scripts and devour code bases
like a college student on an energy
drink binge also maybe all too relatable
making incident resolutions seem like a
breeze it's also that intern that sends
detailed meticulous reports and slides
into your DMs with invaluable insights
the use of slides into your DMs is like
crazy to me like what does it think that
[Laughter]
means but remember no matter how shiny
and impressive it gets it's still a tad
bit clumsy so invest in good old human
resilience and processes as a safety net
after all we're ushering in a thrilling
area of Incident Management one where
our Bots might just bring us our morning
coffee while they're at it I I feel like
I said oh make it inspiring are you guys
inspired by a robot bringing you coffee
it's it's all right cheers to that and
may your future incidents be both few
and swiftly
[Applause]
resolved
thank you thank you thank you uh I'll
advertise where you can get in contact
with me I love talking about this stuff
I love hearing about how other people
are using AI so please reach out to me
on Twitter my DMs are always open I know
Twitter is like the worst site on the
internet right now but I've been too
lazy to go anywhere else um also if you
want to check out some of my writing on
this and other topics uh blameless.
comom athor arnut and then if you want
to just hear me talk about like totally
unrelated stuff mostly like anime uh
some movie reviews uh I have a YouTube
channel too I thought I would just plug
that quick I think I'm getting played
off um so I don't know if there's time
for Q&A I guess not feel free to come
and speak to me if you have any
questions I'll be around I'm I'm here
all week folks all right
[Applause]
byebye